just because your movie is about
something important doesn't mean that
your movie is actually important
would you say filmmakers today are more
concerned with forcing a message or
telling a good story i definitely feel
like more people now are concerned with
forcing a message
uh versus telling a good story
and
you know
say what you will i mean i think that
that can be
it could be a good thing it could be a
bad thing
uh it's it's it's hard to say but i i do
feel like a lot of movies um
i'd say overall have probably been hurt
uh from
being the best movie that they can be
uh when that when they're trying to
focus mostly on
a specific kind of message
because trying to force a certain kind
of message doesn't always make for the
most interesting story um especially if
you have like a certain agenda that you
know that you want to push um
and and it's it's a it's a weird times a
weird world in that sense because
on the one hand
you can say
well
film is about storytelling uh we're just
trying to share the you know human
experience with each other and and
connect to each other in that way and we
do that through stories uh but on the
other hand you can say that you know
film is the most
powerful medium that there is and
therefore it is extremely influential
and therefore
whatever my agenda might be needs to be
represented in that
art form and therefore like i want that
out into the world
so
i understand why people feel like films
need to have a certain type of messaging
i'm a little more in the camp that i
think that we're just here to tell good
stories but i can understand why people
have been indexing so heavily on that i
mean when you look at you know the
academy awards and things etc or award
shows uh it feels like they have to
reward
movies that are important um versus just
movies that have great storytelling um
but a an a a person
uh who is a friend of mine in life had a
great way that they talked about this
where they said you know just because
your movie is about something important
doesn't mean that your movie is actually
important um and i think that right now
there's a lot of movies that are made
about important subjects uh but the
movies themselves aren't actually as
important as they
seemingly portray themselves to be
so yeah that's interesting so the the
topic of the movie is important but the
actual
um
you know story within it the dialogue
the characters it's falls flat yeah the
the execution isn't actually uh doesn't
live up to the importance of the actual
topic
so instead of making sort of um filler
and and
you know
junk food type movies now we're doing it
with
um a purpose in mind but
um there's still the same filler that's
there it's not that there's not a story
that we can really
yeah i think that that's a
a great way to kind of discuss it where
it's like you know a lot of people talk
about oh well we should have movies like
this to you know um engage in the
conversation but a lot of the movies
don't actually
forward the conversation at all they're
sort of um a little bit hollow yeah even
if they have like
a what you would consider an important
message or
dealing with an important subject matter
again that doesn't mean that
the you know the
messages that they actually have in
their film are as important as the
matter itself
sure
sure i mean a lot of
deep topics can be covered in
documentaries and a lot of those
documentaries people unfortunately
sometimes don't want to see which
often i'm attracted to ones that maybe
take a little bit of more of a serious
turn but
when you see award shows
they do seem to shy away
but but if it's wrapped up
with glam i guess we could say then
it might be more acceptable yeah um
maybe they don't feel as true maybe
that's the thing like it's not that we
don't want to see certain issues and
that certain issues don't definitely
exist right but
the way they're done
i think maybe it feels like it's
disingenuous yeah well i mean because
again
being that this is you know filmmaking
as an art form i mean
you know i have such a tremendous amount
of respect for
you know people who have excellent craft
and i think
you know if you're going to do a movie
that has a very important message you
know craft should be extremely important
as well uh because you know we're here
we're in a theater we're gonna watch
your movie and i feel like you know some
of the some of the movies that index
heavily on on messaging uh
maybe try to
make the excuse of like
or not necessarily they're not trying to
make excuses nobody's trying to make a
bad movie but i think that they might
some people might spend too much time
focusing on the message versus having
excellent craft and being able to
cleverly um
cleverly show that message uh through
through the art as opposed to
um just having a beef uh on the
forefront
as an audience member today do you feel
that movies are lecturing to you rather
than
entertaining you
um i feel like a lot of movies uh
can be seen that way
um
but again it kind of relates to
what we were talking about where it's
uh
movies being
focusing on storytelling versus being
focusing on messaging
and i have no problem if a filmmaker or
a movie has a certain type of message
that they want to convey
but
yeah it does become
[Music]
it does become
it takes me out of it if if it becomes
too heavy-handed or too too much of a
lecture because
i'm trying to
experience your world or experience you
know this filmmaker's subjective point
of view and get a new perspective and
learn through these characters
but if if i'm
not organically getting that
message through the art of the story
and there's a lot of illusions to say
what's happening in the real world or
there's a lot of like you know political
topics that are kind of being shoehorned
on top of this story well essentially
you're taking me out of it because not
i'm not just watching your movie i'm
also thinking about
oh this thing that's happening in
the political sphere while i'm watching
your movie so
i think if you're gonna have you know
as you put it like if you're going to
have a message or you're going to
lecture
whatever that that message is
it better be super super cleverly
intertwined within the point of view of
the characters that that we're watching
uh because otherwise you know then
i'll just go watch a ted talk instead
like why would i want to
experience this through the vehicle of
you know filmmaking as opposed to just
listening to somebody talk about it
right are there any movies that you can
think of off the top of your head where
they do
weave in
a message but it's done in a way where
it doesn't feel
overt
i mean like
i feel like a movie like get out does an
excellent job
uh dealing with racism
but in a purely sub-textual kind of way
i mean it's not it's actually pretty
literal i mean it's right there in the
film but through the craft of the story
um that was being told in that film uh
you know
that's where it was really excellently
kind of weaved into the subtext and how
racism exists within uh our current
culture so that's a movie that i think
for instance does an excellent job
having those issues and messaging
service the story that we're watching
so that's a that's one that comes to
mind
what do you love about the film
moneyball what do i not love about the
film moneyball um
i just think it is
such a well-crafted
beautifully told movie
um
that just comes together so well i mean
i think that
just just the whole idea of like the
romanticism around you know the game of
baseball and how that reflects you know
uh
just the human experience and our lives
and everything i think was just so
poetic i mean aaron sorkin of course an
incredible writer uh and just so the
dialogue is always great all the scenes
are great uh just all the execution in
there
um but again that's just a movie i feel
like uh you know referencing
worlds that maybe not everyone enjoys
you know you don't have to be a baseball
fan to watch that movie and still
really really appreciate
the art and the
romanticized poeticism that that comes
from it who is your favorite character
and money mom i mean i love
obviously i think brad pitt's character
is great billy being jonah hill's
character is great but really it's their
it's their dynamic together um
that that's uh it really to me makes the
film work so well
and if we were gonna do
what i said earlier a commenter talked
about psych evaluations my characters on
those two characters just a brief
brief log line psych evaluation on both
um
i guess billy bean is you know he's
he's dealing with uh
just the the feeling of
um you know being being someone who's
cursed in a complete failure who didn't
you know uh
live up to
what he was supposed to um which was to
be this great star baseball player he
felt like he was someone who
was a permanent loser who was cursed um
and
[Music]
jonah hills probably just sort of
represents like uh the
you know the character who just doesn't
fit into this world that is extremely
archaic and has a very specific way of
doing things he's the you know the uh
the misfit amongst this this uh group of
uh
baseball elitists and players and and
organizations so uh yeah just those are
my i guess my analyses of the characters
but he's a misfit but does he let that
stop him is he is he hindered by it the
way the hero is almost hindered by
sort of his achilles heel um
i guess he's not necessarily hindered by
it i mean i think he's
i guess you know now that you're making
me you know write a critical studies
paper on it
um i think probably billy bean just has
more of a like internal uh hindrance
with with everything and then jonah
hill's character is sort of an external
hindrance with it just on how he looks
and you know he sort of reflects the
fact that uh there's a line in the movie
of like you know people are
mischaracterized and judged by
a lot of superficial things like how
they look how they throw a ball how they
run
and joan hill may sort of represent that
in that kind of way where it's like you
know how is this guy gonna teach me
about baseball this nerd who
is obsessed with statistics and looks
super goofy
so i don't know that's his hindrance